[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's dan shaughnessy the boston globe
and uh here's a new book it call it's
called wish it lasted forever life with
larry bird celtics now available online
wherever books are sold really
disappointed in you dan with this book
because
i wish it could have lasted forever it
it's a shorter book like i breezed
through it there were so many great
stories and i kind of went to the end i
go
damn
you know
i needed more out of you dan you let me
down well that's really nice of you dana
thanks for for going through it and bill
walton of course named it and bill
really wishes it lasted forever because
we know his career
could have been so much more but he had
this one gift at the end of his career
the 1985-86 season where bill walden
comes to boston he got 80 games in that
was it he played 10 games the next year
then he retired and you know his feed
pews and all that stuff but
bill said
he said you know empty the thesaurus
when you write this dan he said this is
like i wish this could have lasted
forever everything was great you cannot
overstate how great this was hey this is
a hop back in the wayback machine it's
you know you watch the nba today and i
sometimes long for the 80s i was there
when larry and magic came in and 79 kind
of rescued the league and of course
michael comes in 84 and leading up the
dream team but this was
this this jumped out at me dan during
the pandemic you know when when you know
we're seeing the the espn classics and
30 for 30 on celtics lakers and and here
in boston with no games going on they're
running 80s classic celtics and it's all
we had and i keep seeing my 30 year old
self sitting at the table back in the
day when they they allowed the lowly
media to sit in those seats that they
now sell for five thousand dollars so we
were there
and uh we had access that is never going
to be replicated we were able to tell
the readers and the fans what these guys
are like it was a very fascinating
magnetic team and talented bird mikhail
parish dj
you know five hall of famers they went
to the finals four straight years they
were fun and we live with them i mean
dan you know hotels buses airports
waiting for bags flying commercial
uh this was when the reporters went to
the covid bubble in 2020 they had to
sign a waiver saying they would not
approach anyone if they saw him away
from the facility that's we did all of
our best work i mean the moat has gotten
so wide
here in boston we don't know what's
going on with smart and tatum and brown
because nobody can get near them in
those days we could tell you they're mad
at fish they don't like what the coach
is doing right now they need to change
their casey jones bring them on that
kind of thing it's nobody's fault it's
evolution the way things have gone but
that was kind of what motivated the book
and thank you for perusing through it
and getting some of those fun stories
back in your head was it a 30 for 30 or
a last dance could you see that
possibility i mean it's a shorter time
frame with with these guys and not as
successful but i was i was wondering if
there's enough it feels like but the
stories you tell and there's a little
more drama
you know woven in there but
do you think there's a last dance feel
to the uh the celtics of the 80s
i always do i mean again the
personalities were so strong one thing
because i went from that celtic team
yeah they were 50 and one at home dan
the last year 5001 at home
and i went to major league baseball to
the red sox clubhouse the same year as a
beat reporter and it just struck me how
different it was the climate in there
and i got bruce hurst in the book to
talk about that because you know he
almost won the seventh game of the world
series with those 86 socks and they were
a sour bunch and he said in general
baseball was a sour bunch
because
bruce hurst knew the celtics because he
was friends with danny ainge they played
major league baseball together and
against each other he would come to
practice he knew mikhail he knew bird he
knew parish and he said he said in our
clubhouse you know we harbor personal
feelings and there's insecurities and we
compete against each other to get to the
big leagues it's kind of ingrained in
the culture he says those celtics they
were so secure in their own greatness
there was none of this who's getting
more touches they had fun they had fun
at practice competing against each other
they knew how great they were and this
all comes out you know the kind of trash
talk and you're talking about with guys
whistling and i mean bird that's bird
walking into the three-point contest the
first one ever and saying which one of
you guys is going to finish second i
mean that's bird telling the new york
knicks trainer he's banking
three-pointers during journal warm-ups
before knicks came and the trainer said
it was saunders he said you can't do
that in the game larry if you give me
five bucks i will and then he banked one
in at the end of the game and ran down
by the bench with his palm out looking
for his five bucks i mean he was pool
hustling during the games
uh
the story about xavier mcdaniel
is that true where larry after a timeout
tells x what he's going to do
yeah jackie mcmullen tells that one
really well which is you know i'm going
to do this i'm going to do this i'm
going to do this and then he would do
all those things i was there was a game
in portland he was doing that it was
near the end and he said you better get
somebody over here they were getting
ready to inbound they weren't listening
he pointed and then he took the ball he
drained a three and then he pointed
again coming off he said i told you what
you should have done that was just you
know quinn buckner told me that he could
there was a game called knockout you
know just two guys shooting around in a
gym and quinn said he could he could
knock your ball away from the basket and
make his shot with the same ball he was
playing basketball and pool at the same
time what if social media was around
i'll tell you it changes a lot and again
not in a good way in my view i mean
there was a level of comfort with those
guys i didn't make plans let's go to
dinner let's go have drinks but you
would bump into each other and it was
okay so in fact one night larry picked
up the tab but it was like a total
eclipse of the sun i couldn't believe it
but
most of the time it was just casual and
i think that that casualness is lost
with social media and they don't need us
anymore i mean we're totally nobody
wants to talk to us anymore i understand
that they got you know social media they
got tick tock they got whatever they got
and you know connect they got the
players journal connect with their own
fans and uh we're just now we're old
guys but back then we were all the same
age and uh the money wasn't as great we
lived together the moat wasn't there and
there was a little bit of trust but
still there were times i had to violate
that trust when larry got in his bar
room fight
messed up his hand for the playoffs and
he wasn't too happy about that that's
just the job but that's the tricky part
and i've mentioned on the show i got too
close to mark maguire i got too close to
jason johnson
and you still have to cover them
and i just i made it a point that i was
never going to allow myself to get that
close was there any part of you at that
time that you want to be close to him
gives you access but can you report on
everything you're supposed to report on
you can't do both and again you don't
need to be talking about how many beers
somebody had the night before the game
unless they're in no condition to play
in which case we we would talk about it
mikhail had a pack of guys who would
drive down from the iron range there was
no team in minneapolis but there was a
team in milwaukee this winnebago would
park outside the hyatt when the sellers
were going to play the bucks john nelson
wanted to hire a suite for these guys
because they would take mikael and byrd
and buckner and those guys out there was
a game where
the bucks it was a noon time start think
about that in milwaukee and the night
before on a saturday night
the minnesota crew from from down from
the iron range got all the celtics
wasted and they got beat they got beat
badly and mikhail shot a donut i think
he was over eight or something and casey
jones knew enough not to yeah everybody
knew what had happened casey put his arm
around kevin and said those guys aren't
coming to chicago
and when i talked to mchale about it he
said just hearing those names my liver
starts hurting just hearing those names
and my friends would come down there
well didn't the bulls cheerleaders buy
bird and
that you know roby and those guys beers
one night before a playoff game and
and the celtics won and larry walked off
the floor and said thanks for the beers
with the i
i cannot attest to that one and roby was
robbie was traded for dennis johnson by
the way which is he got a hall of fame
guard for rick robbie who played about
10 games after that but he was traded in
part because he was larry's running mate
at night and that was it was a dual
purpose trade to get dennis johnson and
to get robbie the hell away from larry
bird and it worked on both levels
magically for everybody weren't they the
were they the bru uh bruce brothers or
what is it buckner and roby and bird and
i thought they had a nickname for uh
their crew
there were a lot of nicknames i don't
know that one but they uh uh they they
they socialized and and it was you know
they had all been great college players
at the same time larry was always
jealous of roe because larry wanted to
go to kentucky when he's in high school
and joe b hall didn't think he'd get a
shot off in the sec instead they get
rick robie who was even slower but they
won a championship with him and larry
any time we'd be out you know and
somebody come over from university of
kentucky and shake rick roby's hand
larry would say that's the first time
rick robin ever shook hands didn't have
a 20 bill on the other hand
we're talking to dan shaughnessy the
book is wish it lasted forever life with
the larry bird celtics that'll be your
reaction after you read it you'll wish
that it lasted longer available online
wherever books are sold i didn't
understand or i wasn't aware of the kind
of the undercurrent there with cornbread
maxwell
and
him and kevin mchale that kevin takes
his role and you know cornbread maxwell
you know almost to the detriment of the
team uh you know just wasn't the same
player didn't care as much as uh he did
when he was starting the curve on max i
mean he was he was the man when the
celtics were bad before byrd and mikhail
and paris all those guys got there you
know when havoc was finishing up and
they got bad in the late 70s uh max was
the guy you know he had been a final
four player in north carolina charlotte
he comes to boston he's the man all of a
sudden these guys start coming in and
his touches went down and his shots went
down every year he was in the nba i mean
every year bird comes in then mikhail
comes in maxwell bill fitch takes a
messiah says who do you think is going
to be guard the scoring for the other
team now that's going to be you cedric
you know you know no longer the
offensive force and he got his job done
incredibly he was clutch he's the mvp of
the finals in 81 before you know when
burt's his second year in the league and
the mvp is maxwell and then in 84
maxwell scored 24 points in game seven
against the lakers it was his high game
of the season was game seven of the
finals he never got 24 all year but that
game he said hopping my back boys will
bring it on home he outplayed james
worthy he got inside their heads he was
the guy unfortunately he hurt his knee
after that
and that's where the transition comes in
where he can't play anymore mikhail goes
from six man starts playing mikael gets
56 in one game against the pistons and
max goes i don't think i'm going to be
starting anymore and that was it and you
know there was questions about how hardy
rehab there was a little bit of hard
feelings about that but i mean hey
maxwell his his number's up in the
raptors and and he's he's one of he's
one of the great voices in this book
because he just tells you the truth
about everything if bird had stayed
healthy
finish that
well i think you get a few more years
but he played hard and guys who play
like that the careers i mean we see in
baseball all the time but it's just it's
hard to have a longer you're diving on
the floor mikhail didn't dive on the
floor but mikhail played with a broken
foot in the 87 finals so those injuries
really by today's standards they were
together a long long time they went to
four consecutive finals together they
were in five finals they won three
championships and red always thought he
might have kept him together a little
bit too long and ran through it longer
than he should have instead of making
deals so they by today's standards it's
still a long run you know larry's from
79 to 92 that's still a pretty good run
but again it's not lebron james doing
what he does now yeah but you know and
then you had lenny bias dying uh reggie
lewis like they they
red had it so the transition was going
to be
pretty smooth where the whole you know
the the youth movement coming in was
going to be able to handle any athletes
they were going to face with the lakers
or pistons or bulls
yeah red knew his team was getting old
when they won the championship in 86 and
they went 50-1 at home no one's going to
do that again so he also ends up getting
the best player in the country because
he had traded gerald henderson as
starting guard two years earlier
thinking seattle was going to go bad the
lottery came in they got number two they
got len bias it was all teed up glenn
bias red used to have counselors at his
summer camp bias had been a counselor
for a couple years so they knew exactly
what they were getting his buyers had
basically been working out for him for
two summers and you know rick carlisle
had played with him in the acc everybody
knew what they were getting with that
guy and then you know he drops dead a
day after the draft cocaine intoxication
and the celtics never recovered from
that it was they didn't win again until
2008 when danny ainge was the gm so it
it broke it broke down mikhail had to
play with a broken foot too many minutes
for parrish bird walton's all done and
it just it started to crumble late 80s
when i was working at cnn in new york in
the mid 80s and i would get to come up
for the nba finals and i'd get there and
if it was that sunday and the game was
played later on and i'd go in there when
larry was shooting i'd just sneak into
the building and i would just
it was cathartic
i loved hearing the dribble and i loved
hearing the net
and he never knew i was in there but i
went in there a couple of times and i
was worried that he was going to see me
and then you know he would stop or
whatever it might be
but
no one's in there just somebody
rebounding for him and you just dribble
dribble
dribble dribble
and it was just
it was wonderful it really was yeah that
was a routine at the garden new route 4
4 30 in the afternoon i was an early guy
i'd set up earlier the garden would be
dark be a little bit of light by that
court the the equipment guy was joe
catado larry'd come out he brought him
to indiana when he went there and loved
this guy equipment guy and uh larry do
the perimeter and i'd be setting up in
my stone age computer porter bubble on
the sideline right next to the bench
when they used to let us sit in those
seats the lowly riders had those seats
next to the bench and larry you know he
liked to break chops he'd come over
and uh if he missed a shot during that
thing he'd say that the bull gang set up
the rim something wrong with the rim you
know otherwise that never that would
have gone in
and uh he'd come over and say what are
you working on scoop and i'd say well
i'm doing an early edition newspaper
story about your free throw streak he
was coming up on calvin murphy's 88
consecutive free throws i'm like so
don't miss one in the first half because
this paper is going to go up to maine
it's going to look stupid if they open
it up tomorrow morning and you miss when
i'm writing about the streak this is how
it works
sure enough first half he goes to the
line for two and the foul line is lined
up right where we're sitting if he looks
over he makes the first one he looks
over and winks at me between free throws
and then of course makes the second one
so all was good but he was always
thinking about these things it's like
paying off a bet in the middle of a game
he was doing two things at once
i sat down with him when his career was
over and i went up to boston and brad
lohas said hey if you want to get on
larry's good side bring him up a cooler
and a six six pack of beer and so i
stopped and got a cooler that was like
three dollars and i got a six pack and i
said uh here
and he goes what is it a fish and i go
no it's it's it's beer i said brad lohas
told me to get this for you he goes can
i
can i keep the cooler and i said yes you
can it was a three dollar cool styrofoam
cooler and i go i don't think it helped
me with the interview but it was just
you know that was the mentality of bird
there it's like all right beer cooler
can i have it this is all right i'm good
with this that was the mentality he used
to go to matinees after practice at the
greek orthodox college they practiced in
brookline would say larry how come you
go to matinees he says it's cheaper
cheaper in the afternoon
uh by the way how strong is the mac
jones love in uh new england oh my god
you are all over i mean
i loved it from the start they couldn't
have known you know he would outperform
all the other quarterbacks to this stage
he was 19 for 23 the other day they've
won four in a row they got the titans
game they got the you know atlanta this
thursday and then the titans are coming
in here that that game i don't know if
that's going to get flexed to the prime
time or not but that's a bit's a big
deal now this feels really good dan
because it's it's different and and and
it wasn't expected it's it's ahead of
schedule and rookie quarterback we all
know bill hates him and he's made a
beast off him over the last 20 years so
he's got one of his own now and they're
managing it it's really fascinating to
watch it
evolve congrats on the book and i meant
what i said i wish the book was longer
it was uh that good telling stories and
uh you know taking a trip down memory
lane thank you dan
thank you dan take care dan shaughnessy
the book is i wish it lasted forever
life with the larry bird celtics
available online wherever books are sold